[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du sky échos le magazine
qui vous raconte les aventures
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines permettre au grand
public de réparer soi-même les appareils
d'électroménager voilà la vocation de
l'entreprise sos accessoires implanté
ici à elancourt c'est le leader de la
vente en ligne de pièces détachées
destinées à l'auto réparation depuis sa
création en 2008 près de 40 mille tonnes
de déchets électriques et électroniques
ont été évités en 2021 elle a réalisé
une levée de fonds de 10 millions
d'euros et nous irons découvrir les
coulisses de cette entreprise qui
réalise près de 50% croissance par an
voilà le programme de ce 34e numéro du
sky échos favoriser la collaboration
entre les acteurs de l'emploi et de la
formation le principe de la cité de
l'emploi inauguré le 2 février dernier
c'est une entreprise en pleine
croissance basé à elancourt et soes
accessoires mail vente en ligne de
pièces détachées et auto réparation dans
l'électroménager enfin découverte des
ateliers organisés par laure olivier
grâce à son entreprise au fc création
d'entreprise elle accompagne des femmes
dans leur projet entrepreneurial
nous débutons cette émission avec un
retour sur le lancement de la cité de
l'emploi de saint quentin en yvelines le
président de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous et la ministre en charge de la
vie de nadia ont signé le mercredi 2
février une convention pour la mise en
place de ce dispositif
les explications dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
la cité de l'emploi c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une méthode c'est pas un énième
dispositif c'est pas une énième mesure
c'est tout simplement une méthode qui va
faire converger tous les dispositifs
toutes les mesures de l'emploi vers les
publics qui sont tout simplement ciblées
et ça effectivement c'est assez nouveau
et c'est l'objectif de la cité de
l'emploi
[Musique]
c'est une logique de coordination
d'amplification d'optimisation des
dispositifs qui sont destinés à des
publics plus tôt qu pv et de manière à
rendre plus efficient l'ensemble des
actions qui sont menées sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya beaucoup d'acteurs de l'emploi ils
ont essayé d'intégrer tout le monde bien
sûr mais il faut vraiment voir ça comme
une opération de simplification
m
[Musique]
c'est nous sommes dans l'entrepôt de sos
accesseurs avec son fondateur olivier de
montlivault bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors le sol et ses accessoires c'est
près de 20 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2021 c'est environ 5000
commandes de produits de pièces
détachées par jour c'est ça oui chaque
jour nous vivrons près de 5000 commandes
de pièces détachées électroménager à
destination des consommateurs des à des
particuliers pour leur permettre
justement de réparer leur lave linge
leur fougue leur frigo leurs micros le
leur à leur aspirateur c'est une
sociétés que j'ai fondées donc il ya
treize ans maintenant après avoir
travaillé dizaine d'années chez
l'artiste leader de l'électroménager en
france et je me s'élabore dans la
centrale d'achat accessoires et pièces
détachées c'est clairement là bas que
j'ai identifié un besoin suffisamment
satisfaits pour tous les consommateurs
dans toutes les enseignes à d'ailleurs
arriver à trouver une pièce détachée ou
un accessoire pour entretenir ou réparer
son appareil électroménager et à
l'époque je me suis dit ce ne sont que
des produits de besançon ne sont que des
produits de contraintes il ya peu de
plaisir à aller chercher en magasin donc
le canal internet un canal fantastique
pour distribuer il répondre à ces
besoins qu'on se met donc c'est partant
de cette expérience que j'ai dessiné
décidé de franchir le pas
d'entrepreneuriat et que j'ai lancé a
sauvé ses accesseurs et puis là on le
voit un autre coup est énorme c'est
combien de mètres carrés ici donc là
nous sommes à 2500 mètres carrés mais
vous voyez on est dans un espace qui est
de plus en plus contraints nous allons
déménager dans dans quelques mois dans
un site près de quatre fois plus grande
en au printemps prochain on va en parler
on va détailler justement votre
stratégie mais d'abord pourquoi les
pièces détachées sont essentielles
aujourd'hui pourquoi aussi focalisé sur
l'auto réparation alors finalement de
vous aider les clients à réparer
eux-mêmes leurs produits 17 exactement
ça au départ je dirais une autre notre
marché le marché auquel nous dressions
c'était vraiment ce que j'appelle les
les personnes les plus bricoleuse
c'était ça les débuts de sos accessoires
c'était vraiment vendre des accessoires
et surtout des pièces détachées
technique à ce que j'appelle les super
bricoler mais notre but a vraiment été
particulièrement ces cinq six dernières
années de démocratiser l'auto réparation
en proposant à tout un chacun un maximum
de couple et de services pour les aider
à franchir le pas deux lotos réparation
et 2 surtout à la réussir parce que dans
la plupart des cas c'est assez simple
quand on a la bonne information et la
bonne assistance et c'est comme ça que
le modèle de sos accessoires fortement
évolué et que nous sommes devenus nos
leaders en france par internet de loto
réparation et de vente de pièces
détachées en particulier un leader qui a
levé 10 millions d'euros en 2021 lever
30 10 millions d'euros quelle est votre
stratégie avec à travers ce fonds que
vous avez obtenus et que vous allez
pouvoir investir que se posent dans
l'année 2000 on a déjà commencé en effet
à investir vous avez à vous avez raison
nous avons réalisé donc la plus
importante levée de fonds du secteur au
printemps au printemps dernier dans nos
ambitions sont multiples elles sont
évidemment logistique il faut faire face
à ces volumes croissants
elles sont également commerciale en
france on development tous nos outils et
nos services d'assistance à la
réparation les tutos les vidéos on en a
parlé vous allez les présenter plus
longuement je crois tout à l'heure les
services d'assistance en ligne notamment
de deux visions et un développement à
l'international puisque notre modèle
évidemment et en partie duplicable sur
les pays qui jouxte qui jouxte la france
puisque la plupart des appareils sont
communs aux marchés français allemand
italien espagnol et yoko et on prévoit
un déménagement sur un cycle de quatre
fois plus grand printemps prochain un
bon repas vous êtes tous nos
collaborateurs aujourd'hui nous sommes
70 aujourd'hui sur le sur le site qui se
répartissent pour moitié sur la
logistique vous le voyez il ya du monde
qui travaillent qui travaillent ici et
35 dans les bureaux et est ce qui est
incroyable ici c'est que c'est vraiment
le mariage si je puis dire des métiers
les plus traditionnels avec les métiers
les plus récents les plus geeks les plus
sains et plus techno ici chez sos
accessoires vous avez des techniciens
électroménager chevronné vous avez des
magasiniers mais vous avez également des
dates analystes les développeurs
un web des rois
du web et du webmarketing nous
permettent justement de proposer de
manière moderne ce service qui somme
toute est vieux comme le monde la
réparation ou l'aide à la réparation
merci olivier de mon niveau merci à vous
je rappelle que vous êtes le fondateur
de cette société dont sos accessoires et
puis maintenant je crois qu'il ya un
tutoriel qui est en cours de tournage
l'a justement je vous montre
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint le studio de sos
accessoires l'endroit où sont réalisés
les tutoriels est avec nous le hic le
goff bonjour bonjour
technicien électro ménager un espace que
vous partagez avec martin le cadreur
monteur de ces vidéos alors est ce que
vous nous expliquer votre quotidien ici
or le but est de justement monter des
vidéos afin d'aider au maximum les gens
dans l'auto réparation afin d'acquérir
une certaine autonomie et
par le biais d'autres d'autres supports
en aide on les aide au quotidien
là vous étiez en train de réaliser une
vidéo c'était quoi alors ces cinq
astuces justement pour prolonger la
durée de vie de son appareil en
l'occurrence actuellement on travaille
sur les lave vaisselle comment ça se
passe en fait c'est vous qui écrivez vos
textes ses dépenses réalisées alors
principalement oui c'est moi qui écrit
les textes mais de temps en temps il
m'arrive de demander de l'aide à martin
à marie ou à mes collègues qui
travaillent au service technique de de
travailler aussi dessus ça c'est une
partie de votre activité parce que vous
êtes aussi dans l'espace service
après-vente en quelque sorte c'est ça on
fait des vidéos mais aussi on fait des
tutos des tutos écrit d'études des
réponses aux appels téléphoniques
par visio et tout autre support comme
mail presta et autres pour justement
aider nos clients à s'auto répare dans
la question laïque quel sens vous donnez
à votre activité au quotidien c'est
rendre service et ça oui c'est une chose
que j'ai découvert au fil de l'eau fil
des années en grandissant que j'aimais
ce côté de rendre service est vraiment
d'aider les gens à s'auto réparer c'est
devenu une vraie passion merci un métier
merci loïc lamboeuf merci et je vous
propose tout de suite regardé comme un
extrait de vos prestations
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je sui loïc de chez sos
accessoires si vous constatez sur les
programmes à chaleur tournante que les
listes ne tourne plus que votre four
chauffe mal ou que celui-ci est bruyant
c'est que vous avez peut-être un
problème avec le moteur ventilateur de
chaleur tournante en partenariat avec la
cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines leurs oliviers organise des
ateliers autour de l'entrepreneuriat
féminin
une initiative dans le cadre de sa
société baptisée au fc création
d'entreprise est lancée en 2020
la prochaine rencontre a lieu le 15 mars
prochain faisons un retour tout de suite
sur la première rencontre qui s'est
déroulée le 8 février dernier
je suis en biais et je vous accueille
dans le cadre d'une formation à
destination des femmes futurs
entrepreneurs
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on part de la
prochaine rubrique ce pourquoi vous êtes
doué donc je vois si tu ce projet devait
vous êtes connu à travers votre réseau
vos amis donc fatalement on vous dit que
vous avez un bon relationnel vous mettez
en réseau les gens et ça ça fait partie
des éléments pour lesquels vous êtes le
plus beau est peut-être reconnu là
dessus
la prochaine étape c'est ce que vous
aimez par exemple quand tu vois on nous
disait que le développement personnel
l'a découvert ça est en fête lui plaît
donc vous faites des recherches vous
êtes toujours en veille là dessus vous
aussi de vous améliorer son bien ça peut
voir que ce que vous aimez si froid la
transmission des transmissions bref ça
donc ça si je pense qu'il faut
développer là dessus parce que ça c'est
ce qui va qu'il reflète en fait vos
valeurs et vos ambitions leur projet
entrepreneurial
on se pose trop de questions et le fait
de se poser des questions en fait ça à
vous mélangez situation d'immobilisme où
on ne passe pas à l'action donc quel
statut de les choisir pour comment je
vais concilier ma vie ma vie de maman et
ma vitre ma vie de futurs entrepreneurs
comment je vais faire court on a
retraite comment toutes ces questions a
en fait la vie paralyse et ses questions
à qui vous empêche de passer à l'action
un homme qui ne faussera pas les mêmes
questions la gdc sympathique là on est
nous on est là et petit à petit on
élargit sa zone de confort et grâce à
l'action qu'on compte qu'on va avoir
abusé de conclure rien n'est parfait tu
vois
c'est aussi le perfectionnisme du fait
de on contrôle tout ils font tout soit
parfait tu vois ça ça n'existe pas votre
première action elle sera dure au moins
gras que la financière action c'est la
fin de ce caillou merci de l'avoir suivi
une émission que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]